former world number one tennis player
one of only eight gentlemen to win the
men's singles career Grand Slam eight
time Grand Slam winner and goat in his
own right here courtesy of Lavazza the
global Italian coffee company an
official US Open sponsor none other than
Andre Agassi how are you sir
Hey good thanks for having me I'm doing
well it's been a long time since we have
chatted so what is life like for you
give me a picture of the Andre Agassi
okay I am I am I'm happy we'll start
with that that's good I'm happy I'm good
yeah it's been interesting
you know journey last five years figured
out some ways to scale mission in Vegas
I started with my own school and and and
economically challenged area and now I
figured out a way to scale early and
sustainability
make greater to you know change and
built up III schools over the last four
and a half five years across the country
so it's been it's been challenging but
rewarding sort of solving for the
daunting societal issues you know what
did you think of lebron opening his
school in Akron oh listen I think it's a
wonderful thing I mean any is never
enough it's never enough I mean
everybody needs to to partake in in our
future and give them a platform for for
future of their choosing assist that too
not at a crime and it's been my passion
and it's great to see him caring about
it yeah why did you choose that
Adri I mean I don't know if he played
psychologist on myself here I guess
what's in my lack of education was a was
a big reason for it I mean I didn't have
choice in my life it was tennis since I
was born my father kind of you know
chose that for me and you start to
recognize at some point that that there
are kids out there that really don't
have choice and it doesn't mean you know
being the best in the world as a sport
it means you know it means an
environment that they they can't break
out of and and and the cycle of activity
that doesn't that doesn't add to our
world so if you could just give those
kids a chance to kind of
break that downward spiral that you know
there's there's a tremendous amount of
reward in that and then it was
responsible for the second half of my
career and and I'm certainly indebted to
it and it gives me more than I give it
and he'll the reason I wake up every day
yeah I bet so are your kids not picked
up a racket at all are you not exposing
them to that world in a way
oh well not much kids anymore they're
almost 17 and 15 16 and 14 currently and
you know my son as baseball has been
that's been you know six years old so I
mean my daughter was hip-hop dance for a
lot of years and now she's 14 15 year
old you know teenager so probably enough
said as it relates to the challenges
that you know those intersections bring
but it's you know it's kind of a blessed
life watching them not knowing what
they're in for so the answer's no I
we weren't motivated to necessarily in
addition the tennis uh didn't feel
compelled to do so and they certainly
didn't choose it as they had you know
plenty of options for their own life and
we just hold them accountable to what
they claim they value and make sure that
they're living it okay so what sort of
ballplayer do you have there in your son
Andre all right I mean I just you just I
could just tell you it's like whether he
was a committee to see as a freshman in
high school he's a junior now he's a
two-way player third-base pitcher you
know he sees me as a chance that met his
dreams you know I mean you know it's not
like tennis we eat which he kills so
other people have to think so in the
sport and you know he'll figure it out
along the way but he's uh you know he's
doing it himself so what did you say
it's not like tennis you said eat what
you kill is that what you said about
tennis yeah yeah what I mean by that is
if you can so you can win nobody can
stop you it doesn't matter if they like
you it doesn't matter if they think your
game is good or they think you're you're
not good you get out there and get the
job done and you know you uh you know
you move forward I mean other other team
sports don't always have that luxury you
know people
need to invest in you people need to
believe in you people need to give you
the opportunity and then you gotta make
the most of the opportunity you know so
it's a it's a different it's a different
animal but but you know not not quite
not quite the same okay so Jaden is
touching what on the gun if he's a
freshman commit to USC Andrey he hit 93
this summer and you know plugging along
he's a big boys kind of gotten some
genes from somewhere I don't know maybe
so so baby but she still not touching
your serve on the gun essentially he
picked up a racket and I gave him a week
that wouldn't be an issue hitting
something okay okay andre agassi here on
the Rich Eisen show so how plugged into
you I guess sorry did you watch say
Nadal last night which went to I guess
11 o'clock Las Vegas time I mean did you
yeah no I did it was epic it was
memorable it was two warriors you know
going at it it was everything that makes
me so thankful I get to watch it now
instead of deal with well I mean what do
you like like watching this I mean are
you sitting there with your wife with
Stephie and just watching tennis and
what do you talk about when you watch a
match like say last night that went
almost five hours well you know we're
not sitting together necessary watching
that match when I was in New York last
night I made it here you know and enough
time to they kind of settle into that
match but but for me you know it's all
tennis is problem-solving you know so it
doesn't take long especially when you
know that guys and what their what their
strengths and weaknesses are and then
how those met and how the matchups
really are going to play out I mean I
called an epic match that the doll was
going to win before it started but that
doesn't mean that it's going to happen
and and you kind of watch everybody make
their little adjustments out there or
story in real time you know I enjoy that
part of it I enjoy why
- you know Nadal solve for you know an
ass-beating in the first set I enjoy
watching TV make the adjustment to that
I enjoy watching you know how they
handle some of those big moments and how
they don't treat those big moments any
differently than they may treat you know
other moments in the mess so there's
there's a there's a lot to take in there
when you when you've done it so what's
the toughest match you ever played then
Andre Agassi did you get your ass beaten
in the first set of that one so that
love match I got it but I guess a tennis
match
Andre an actual competition yes so so
you can say person you know who
typically presented the challenges or
you could say in hindsight this match
was the toughest and you know winning
losing right so I have my list of which
match cost me the most in my heart and
mind which match gave me the most of my
heart in mind and you know when it comes
to the ladder it was the French Open the
last of the four Grand Slams being down
to six 11 the finals a microcosm of my
life and then figuring out a way to get
over the finish line that when you talk
about matches that kind of ripped my
heart out I'll never forget 295
you know US Open final where I was 26
and L going into the final and wasn't
wasn't quite good enough on the day and
and I was 26 and one when that summer
ended and I wish I was given away 25
other matches that summer just to won
that one so it you know he just there's
a flood of memories and you know when
you played 12 14 other matches and your
life you uh you know it seems like you
remember sometimes everyone well a
couple more minutes left with Andre
Agassi here on the Rich Eisen show so
much conversation these days not about
Serena's tennis unfortunately about her
her garber choice of garb and it seems
that the Parisians will not let her wear
her cat suit because it's disrespectful
you you have
some years about your garb in your
playing career and Wimbledon etc so I'd
love to ask you what do you think of
this hole if you will set to with the
Serena Williams's choice of tennis where
well you know this is he's an athlete
and to me when she wears up like that it
it just shows more of what an athlete
she is and and and you know and it's not
not a big deal to me personally but but
you know I remember playing in Paris and
at the time you know the president of
the Federation had an issue with what I
wore and suggested that they should move
to the Wimbledon kind of dress code and
and my comment at the time was if you
want to move to limbo and Jesco then
moved to the Wimbledon you know and
those sponsorships on the court deal too
so I as a business you have to make a
decision and what I make the same
decision I I would not you know Serena
wearing a cat suit as far as I'm
concerned helps my business and you know
so it all depends what your perspective
is the tradition of the game you know
morphs and changes over the years and
one can always argue if a change is good
or not playing the open semifinals on a
Saturday followed by Sunday now given
the guy's a day off you know puts an
asterisk next to every other champion
that ever played this game so you know
when you make these decisions you can't
you can't make them in a vacuum you have
to you have to really consider it in
context of of not just where the sports
been but where you also want it to go
and you know I suppose they have the
right to do it but I would understand
you know Serena's right to wear what she
wants and I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you about the just do it campaign since
it's so many people are talking about it
the 30th anniversary of it Colin
Kaepernick is the choice of Nike to be
the face of it what are you as a former
face of that campaign think of
Kaepernick's choice yes Nikes choice
correct you know you know you know you
know Nike has proven that they are the
best in the world when it comes to you
know being on the cutting edge of where
that company wants to go they have a
clear
vision and purpose in mind and and
sometimes over the years it's been just
for the sake of controversy you know I
mean so I don't know what's happening in
those boardrooms and I don't know the
reasons for any choices they make I
think that you know Cabernets should
probably feel pretty good that he's
associated with a company like Nike now
should Nike feel the same apparently
they do so we'll see how that plays out
in the American lens but but it's not
not something I can comment on when I
don't understand you know what their
what their objective is and you are
however on behalf of Lavazza joining us
on the show today the coffee company
from Italy that's the official US Open
sponsor what are you doing with them
Andre Agassi yeah so we've been together
for a handful of years and either of us
has been obviously a company you know
well you know family business or you
know well over a hundred years and
they've now gotten into tennis on a
comprehensive level and supporting them
supporting the game has been a reward
for me and it of itself being that the
game is giving me possum in my life
given also the fact of their values as a
company and what they've done and
continue to do on behalf of my
foundation and my and my work and
efforts in the in the in the you know in
a community and you know back home
I just this has been a relationship with
two two brands that have spent a great
deal of time and pride in building you
know who and what they are coming
together to have to have multiple people
be winners as a result and I consider it
to be you know thousands of children's
lives so it's a win across the board and
and I you know I I drink to coffee and I
enjoy the coffee and you know I just
kind of get it free on top of there's a
couple of Aussie cafes at the US Open
this week I'm assuming you had to hit
one of them to stay awake for last
night's match ending at 200 something in
the morning yeah I did I started
I mean when I son and I'll get his teeth
in the match was the first cup and then
when they moved in the the fifth set I
started kind of backing off the caffeine
because some all good things have to
come to an end and now you know thank
goodness the US Open has the sense that
tie breakers in the state they're god
forbid we we found ourselves in a in a
battle that's going to determine you
know the next match winner before it
even begins so it's it's one of the
reasons why I believe tie breakers
should implement it if you don't know
who's won a match by six on the fifth
guess what let's go home and flip a coin
right I don't know if you're aware I
guess a quick trivia question for you do
you know what your longest match of your
career was you know I can tell you
tennis score lines but but you know I
never paid attention to the clock
because I was only interested and the
wear and tear that my opponent was was
feeling or wasn't feeling um you know so
I played as deep as nine seven in the
fifth but some some actual time
perspective I would not know no I have
an answer for you it's a five setter
that stretched from Thursday into a
Friday at the US Open in 2006 against
Marcos Baghdatis
in that one you thought you took that
was a long-ass match actually
technically uh yeah I mean I know the
obviously the match well I played Blake
seven six months fifth as well and you
know I've had many that have gone the
distance but but from again from a time
perspective you never quite know the
rhythm that guys are playing that and
how long it lasts
can't even imagine what it's what does
it like to sleep on knowing that you
have a match that's open but you already
just shot I mean you you must be going
over shots in your head how do you even
get to sleep over something like before
after yeah just a just when you have to
go from Thursday into a Friday with a
match still alive that's that's kind of
crazy you think about it well youyou
mean Thursday to Friday because my plan
past midnight right yeah yeah yeah so
will playing past midnight I mean I
don't I don't turn into a pumpkin past
midnight I mean I'm still a that's true
hey Andre it's great to chat with you
man
really I've missed the chats and
certainly if you're in Los Angeles would
love to have you in here
Congrats on everything is great - great
to hear your voice Sammy that's andre
agassi
hall-of-famer the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience